what's the biggest question you've got
this morning besides can you get a free
one right well you know I guess that's
how Apple is going to merchandize a
product with so many variations right
this is unique in Apple's history you've
got you know three different kinds of
Apple watch you've got the Mustaine lyst
steel Apple watch the sport edition in
case an aluminum and then of course the
gold edition which matt and i'll be
running out to buy that you've got two
sizes of watch base for 42 millimeters
and 38 millimeters and then all these
different bands you know how are they
going to present it in the apple retail
stores and of course ha what will the
prices be it starts at 349 how high oh
let go it's a lot of complexity for an
apple product they're gonna have to come
up with a new way of selling it what do
you think Jeff um so you know it's apple
and good morning my name is Tiffany it's
apple so it's gonna be important but as
an apple fanboy I will actually not rush
to go and buy because I want to
understand what is the use case what is
gonna make me replace my set of watches
because the last thing I want is to have
yet another connected device on my body
I'm very happy with my with my
smartphone I'm not convinced yet as to
why I should be buying the Apple watches
in the sports tracking capabilities is
that the window on my phone the fact
that apparently they will have smart
notifications that tell me hey someone
is trying to text you and as opposed to
picking up my phone will look at my
watch I think it's gonna be pretty
awkward kind of interaction so I want to
see how people use it before I make my
decision by Jeff it's also a high-end
product what about the fact that
high-end guys love the current watch as
they where are they suddenly going to be
putting away their Rolex parties and I
WCS it's certainly a you know notion of
connected Rory is a marketer is just
starting we've seen connected sort of
rings for for women we now have
smartwatches let's not forget that up
until now it sounds like the market has
been sending about what million to
millions of units and to apple this is
nothing obviously if they were making a
toaster they would actually sell a
million units so it's sort of trying to
figure out what is what is success for
Apple I agree with you if you have sort
of a high-end
watch what would you serve use the Apple
watch and maybe you would sort of rotate
them I'm not I'm not against that notion
but I'm it confuses to as Brett said how
will apple so market this where there
are so many variations and so many sort
of reasons to buy and where to watch
yeah Brad I mean I'm guessing they're
gonna not aim at the highest end clients
who have on an IWC pilot's watch they're
looking for somebody who would maybe be
in the market for a swatch or a g-shock
instead right no yeah that's right well
look I mean you know to make a dent in
Apple's revenues this has to be a huge
market right i mean this is a company
that earned that brought in revenue 200
billion over the last four quarters so
they need a huge market here i think
this is the beginning this is a
placeholder and as the Apple watch
develops more sensors or have more
health monitoring capabilities it will
start to appeal to a wider audience but
we're gonna we're gonna have to see
today is what it does what what the apps
do and whether it does have a widespread
appeal Brad many of us last week we're
saying ten thousand dollars for a gold
Apple watch who's gonna pay that but
just yesterday Scott Galloway was saying
I'll tell you who's gonna buy it China
do you agree you know it this will be
the ultimate representation of
conspicuous consumption that the people
that will buy that gold edition watch
are the ones that want their friends to
know they are the kind of people that
would buy the gold edition watch so you
know I don't think Apple sells many of
them I agree it may partly be targeted
at the Chinese market but you know you
have to ask a question why would you buy
such an expensive device when it will
probably be obsolete in a year maybe two
right and Jeff I figure they have to aim
at Brad was talking about the health
component so they're going to aim at
jawbone you can imagine that they would
aim at like son toe and polar can fit
that isn't that a bit bit but they're
not going to be aiming at rolex or
cartier i mean how there's no way they
can I can't imagine they could get that
market yeah but then the Quadi issue is
really the price point the first Apple
watch starts at friend 49 the basic
Fitbit is 59 by
and it doesn't need to be recharged
every day so as I said to Stephanie when
I was not in New York there's really
sort of a different use case here again
where someone really wants to monitor
their sleep and their health in that and
the activity will wear a device on the
left wrist and then they will have a
watch on the right wrist so i'm actually
not buying the the notion that a an
apple watch will be a stronger better to
do a fitbit which is today 70 episode
it's a possible jeff that apple does not
hit a home run with this product i mean
i just can't see why it would be the
next thing you have to have rather than
just a novelty look this is this is the
ipod version one it's not gonna be
perfect it's gonna be beautiful for
people who sort of enjoy it and like it
and Apple will sort of certainly learn
from it and you know I'm tempted for
once do not buy version one but to wait
for version 2 which I'm sure will will
be smaller will be will have a longer
battery the big question here is how
long is the battery life is it going to
last for the entire day Apple has
integrated this this watch mode where if
the battery is too low it will just
display the time that tells you that
they know they will have battery issues
are the Fitbit folks worried at all or
does Apple getting into the game in a
big way just make the connected world or
consumers interest in it all the more
important I would say definitely the
latter i think that Fitbit has enjoyed a
leadership position in this mark at
seventy-five percent of the market as
witty as we said and now apples are
getting in play in the market will just
do one thing which is legitimize it Brad
do you feel like there's really that
much hype around this I mean I can
remember when the first or second
versions of the iPad or the iphone came
out it was a super huge deal and I just
don't get that consumers are as excited
about it at least not from here what's
it like in cupertino it may be a little
bit of a harder sell I mean look this is
a very different kind of product
category for Apple
for consumers we've seen other kinds of
wearable devices most obviously Google
glass really fail you know I think
everyone in computing agree is that
these devices are getting more personal
they're leaving our desks our offices
they're coming onto our bodies I kind of
connected watch is an inevitability so
you know I see this is the beginning of
a big mountain that Apple and all
computing makers have to climb what does
success look like this may be a slower
burn than other apple products but Brad
Tim Cook is closely tied to Nike and we
saw nike I'm not gonna say fail with the
FuelBand but it clearly wasn't a success
that's right and you know Nike Nike
close that mission and laid some people
off but nike sonic a computer company a
technology company an apple is this is
the first major product category
launched under tim cook he is really
personally associated with fitness and
wellbeing this is a big bet for him so I
think he's got a lot of his credibility
on the line here and and pre launching
it in September doing another event now
in March you know it shows that Apple's
been a very thoughtful about how to
introduce a new product category and how
to get people an app developer starting
to think about it I wonder if we start
see people wearing more than one watch
remember the 80s when people would put
on like six different swatches that was
just a style thing Jeff what do you what
do you think about the fact that
FuelBand didn't work for Nike is that
any threat to this connected world no I
think it's nike I just didn't have a hit
product FuelBand was a pretty crappy
product to be honest the news shows
exactly what's getting technically
speaking ust he was telling consumers
that they had few points and you didn't
know what that meant right you were sort
of walking you were running and saying
you had points and so just miss the mark
on the consumer experience I think that
there is definitely a legitimate sort of
market there you know smartwatches is
still small spot strikers is you know
another Madrid bigger but is still small
and I think that Apple Japan the fray
will sort of get people interested in
what's going on with the wrists and
we'll figure out whether they they vote
with their feet and buy one watch we'll
figure out that sports tracker activity
tracker sleep tracker
is definitely a better option for them a
good thing though that we're in the
early innings of that market opportunity
from a clumsiness standpoint do you see
people willing to charge their watch
every night it's gonna be awkward it's
already sort of a pain to think about
charging your cell phone you know every
day sometimes multiple times of that and
if you have to sort of think about the
watch the watch is something that you
remove all you wear in the case of a
sleep tracker but thinking about
charging it it's gonna be like awkward
to that and you know if you don't charge
it it won't have battery for the next
day I don't take my watch off at night
when I go to bed you know I mean my
problem is my sleep tracker my FuelBand
my Fitbit I wear a jawbone I take it off
when I sleep you still do that kind of
thing I'd I thought people only did that
for a few months and I mean I'm not
gonna lie i have said that my nightstand
is a bit of a fitness tracker graveyard
i have a lot of them in there but I wear
a jawbone up and I like it